[Music]
here we go
1931 and again we are playing with the
white pieces
and again i'm gonna play one e4
okay yeah i'll go over that herb master
i'll be sure to go over that after the
game so he plays d5
this is called the scandinavian opening
and i have a very fun fact about the
scandinavian i'll share
uh after the game now the reason that i
don't recommend this candy to most
players is because
you bring the queen out early very early
before the other pieces if you've seen
searching for bobby fischer
you you'll know that that's another
great chess movie
in the movie the main character he has a
problem with bringing the queen out
early the problem with bringing the
queen out early
is that i'm able to develop my pieces
and attack the queen at the same time
which gives me a lead in development in
addition i'm going to control the center
now by playing d4
continue my development normally you
want to develop your knights before your
bishops
and this is what and maybe somebody with
a little bit less experience remind me
what this is called and how do we defend
against this what can we do
about this this is called a pin i can't
move my knight i would drop my queen
and the way that we can defend against
the pin there's two main ways
we can try to get this bishop out of the
picture
or we can intercept the pin with one of
our lesser value pieces
in which case we can now move our knight
and that would simply lead to a bishop
trade
that's fine we don't need to move our
knight we just can if we wanted to so
now we're going to continue developing
now we're going to continue developing
and now let's centralize our knight
and when i say centralized i mean
literally put a piece on one of the
central squares
where the piece is the most active now
we haven't completed our development
there is a bishop the bishop has not
been developed where should we put this
bishop
let's give him a taste of his own
medicine
let's give him a taste of his own
medicine yeah we got a huge raid from
charlie
f5 uh so i think you guys mean g5 yep
bishop to g5 what is this this is a pin
but look at
his position he's passive here he's
really cramped on these last couple rows
look at my pieces they had a bishop
knight they're all well placed
and guess what when all of your pieces
are well placed like this you
immediately need this and
charlie would be the first to say this
you got to think about attacking
now in order to attack we need to open
up some files and
avenues toward his king uh and one idea
that comes to mind look at this rook
very carefully
do you remember guys in the last game i
had a plan let me very quickly show you
oh it doesn't let me look at the last
game so i had a plan where i basically
opened up that
f file sorry one sec oh there it is
i basically needed to open up that f
file
by playing knight d2 f4 and f5
can you see the parallel here what can
white do here it's the same exact plan
we can go f4 f5 open up the file for the
rook
and this rook is also going to put a lot
of pressure on the knight so that's
where pattern recognition happens that's
why i always emphasize to people
if you want the fastest way of improving
look at your own games figure out your
mistakes
figure out what you should have done and
you can use the computer for that
and and try to build off of that try to
kind of collect in your mind or even in
a real notebook
uh the various ideas and the plans that
you think are cool that you could apply
in a future game that's what makes chess
so magical
there's always an x game and there's
always an opportunity to correct your
mistakes
so let's see what he does now c5 would
be no problem we would just take on c5
and arcane can be tucked away into the
corner here where it's very safe
and uh he's in some trouble he's in some
trouble because we're about to play f5
we can also bring this rook into d1 in
order to support
the pawn on d4 why would we do this
because he might move his bishop back
and if he moves his bishop back
then his queen is going to attack our
pawn uh it would be a good idea to
defend it
okay it's not that i don't care about
the clock um
but i think the explanation is more
important now can we play them with f5
is that a good idea
or do we want to prepare it what do you
guys think
there's actually something better that
we can do well there's there's quite a
coup there's quite a few good things we
could do
i think that we should go f5 let's see
what happens
in a tournament game i actually myself
would not play f5 and i'll explain
why after the game but he takes
now what well we can recapture we could
also capture his knight but there's no
need to do that
let's accumulate the pressure rook takes
five now the file has been opened
okay now things get really interesting
okay so let's unpack this situation we
have a knight here how many times has
the knight defended
one two three the knight is also being
attacked three times we don't need to
worry about it
because uh the knight is defended the
same number of times that it's being
attacked
so one thing that we would consider
doing here is bringing all of the pieces
into the game
we can do that in several different ways
so one of them is to go rook 8 to f1
this is called doubling the rooks
where the two rooks are stacked on the
same file and this increases the
pressure on the f-file
now he's got a very very strong move
here he doesn't find it he plays
takes and now this is a fork it is true
we are also pinned it's the same thing
we saw in the last game
we're forked but we fork him but we're
also pinned
but still look at his knight that night
is under so much pressure look at all of
our pieces staring it down
as soon as this knight is captured that
king is going to be in huge show because
he's going to recapture with a pawn
he's going to have to okay and he finds
a cool idea but it doesn't well does it
work though
these people are good ladies and
gentlemen so
he seems to blunder a bishop let's see
what his idea is
and he gives me a fork he forks my king
in the rook
are we screwed are we screwed
we are not we can drop the ruck back
we can drop the rook back simultaneously
defend against the check and the fork
and now we're simply up a piece he plays
knight d5 we capture it
and uh now all we need to do and we have
a very cool idea i'm going to
un-pin myself i'm going to unpin myself
he takes my reign he resigns
now there was something very cool here
if he would have taken my rook
and i'll explain everything what would i
have done in this position i would not
have recaptured his rook which would be
fine
there is actually a very cool checkmate
thank you thank you kwams and and we had
a sub that i missed i apologize for that
thank you um rod yakassa for the sub
queen takes f7 is backrank made exactly
take stakes and good by kingovich
exactly okay so let's walk through that
and as you can see the opponents are
getting better these games are
are becoming more competitive which is
what's making this fun
now he played the scandi okay knight f3
bishop b2 again unpinning ourselves so
that the knight can now move
we did move the knight did i blunder the
pawn here why didn't i
why didn't my opponent take on d4 what
was my idea who can tell me
yeah and i'll show you guys everything
in a moment well what this move
accomplishes
is that it opens up the opens up the d
file as we've already seen
you want to be careful about giving
rooks open files because open files can
lead to checkmate
very very quickly thank you five nor
latch for the tier one
his queen has to move back just visually
look at how active my pieces are his
pieces are basically on their initial
squares
black is in very big trouble um
well i have a story about the scandi
i've told this story before
funny story and then we'll move on for
the game uh to the game uh the year is
about 1895
and two strong british players are
facing each other
so in the 1800s there used to be a very
old rule in tournament chess
that if you touched a piece that had no
legal squares you had to move your king
okay that was just a rule uh in order to
discourage people from you know just
touching all the pieces
right nowadays it's you don't you're not
punished for that
but it is touch move if you touch a
piece an official tournament chess
you have to move it so this guy
touches the bishop on c1 and
maybe he you know looked at the position
wrong or hallucinated now the bishop has
no legal squares right it's blocked in
by its pawns
so he had to move his king and he chose
the most disastrous time to do it what
does black have in this position this is
one of the shortest games in chess
history
because amazingly black has the move
queen e4
checkmate this is not a mate that
everybody's familiar with it's a
three-move checkmate
not the fastest that's possible but look
at white's king and the queen they're in
a standoff
king has no squares the queen controls
all of them a little
rhomboid shape here anyways i think that
guy did not have a very good day after
that
but let's go back to the game so
essentially
he didn't take our pawn we pinned his
knight why didn't we play the move
knight e4 applying pressure on his
knight on f6
the reason is very much the same
remember again
connect the patterns bishop b2 unpinning
us from this pin and symmetrically
he can do exactly the same thing you can
play bishop e7 his queen is no longer
pinned and the knight on f6
is now very very well defended so i can
trade a bunch of pieces here
but that's not good for me training
pieces lessens the intensity of the
attack
when you're attacking you need pieces to
deliver checkmate
with and that's why i played f4 okay so
f4 f5
takes takes rook to f1 and then he finds
this very cool idea bishop takes c5 and
queen d4
so this is a fork because he's attacking
the king and the rook if i move the king
he takes the rook i can't take back
because his queen is defending the rook
a rookie three is the defensive move now
he had a better try here than what he
did
he could have what was this better try
what was this better try oh why wouldn't
i play f5 in tournament chess
so the reason i wouldn't play f5 is
because i was a little bit scared
of his response queen to b6 attacking
the pawn on d4
if i was playing a grandmaster i would
have played a slower move
such as rook to d1 so knight to g4 you
guys are absolutely correct
um knight g4 was a better try it's the
same exact thing as after knight d5
except i don't control that square
so he wants to take my rook can somebody
spot
white's response i had seen this and i
calculated one step ahead
queen e3 he still takes the rook with
the queen
it's not knight d1 although you're very
close it's not queen f3 either
if we try queen f3 i understand what you
guys want to do
but remember in comparison to that thing
we talked about he's got two rooks on e8
so queen f8 is not back right mate smash
factors
amazing some of you are getting it the
move is rook to d1
how do i come up with this move what
does it do two things that it does we
attack the queen
right we attack the queen so if he takes
our rook
with either piece then we take his queen
and if you calculate the variation
then at the end of the day white is up a
whole piece i am up a bishop
that's huge that's winning if he takes
with the knight
now i'm up a queen now you might be
looking at this and saying okay but no
problem
i mean can't he just move his queen back
to b6 and
once again we're faced with the same
idea of him taking on e3
but this is what you have to do you
always have to try to detect
how the position changes as a
consequence of the last couple moves
if you look very carefully at this
position you can't play rookie 8 because
of the pin
that's what a pin is that is illegal
because the king will be under fire
right this is what a pin is you you
cannot expose your king by it by law
so if you look at how the position has
changed it changed
change it you can now take the knife the
knight is no longer defended
he takes the rook we take the rook he
takes the bishop
we move the king away the smoke is
cleared and white is now up a night
okay what about rook to f4 great
question
rook to f4 has the same idea but it's
the wrong execution
jimmy garoppolo would find this move
instantly because there's an
interception that happens we
ins we accidentally intercept uh i'm a
big 49ers fan yes and i'm kind of sour
about how things are going
the rook on e3 is no longer protected
and uh i am from the bay area by the way
anyways uh so that's
basically the idea now queen f2 to unpin
ourselves and attack f7
which caused them to resign
which caused them to resign okay
doosan five five five and we're playing
with the black pieces
let's play the situation lucas aiden the
sicilian is when you play c5 and the
opening that i have been playing
almost exclusively well never mind
because he does not play the main line
which is d4 he plays c3
this is called the aleppo and sicilian
uh named after a lithuanian chess player
his idea is to prepare to control the
center with the move d4
okay now what we need to do here as
black is we need to
immediately contest the center with our
pieces
so we're going to get the night out in
order to attack his pawn
so that he doesn't have a chance to play
before he goes bishop to d3
take bologna thank you that's not a
great move
because now we can occupy the center and
his bishop has
blocked the other bishop from coming out
which is something you want to really
a situation you want to try to avoid
he's got e5 attacking our knight
can somebody tell me where should we put
this knight where should we go
in order to attack this pawn white is
not worse here this is a line
but yeah knight g4 let's get to this
pawn let's try to win it
now his correct move yep he plays it
correctly very nice it goes bishop b5
uh to attack my knight the usual
let's un-pin that knight so the knight
can once again move there's a lot of
trap this is a
line i used to study ah but ladies and
gentlemen
we have a very sexy move here look at
this bishop
we've encountered this tactic many times
before
and those of you just joining i'll show
you guys after the game the precedent we
can play knight takes e5 i think
if i'm calculating this right i might be
dropping a piece here
now what what am i doing well what i'm
doing is that this bishop
look at it very carefully it's hanging
which means if he takes the knight we
take his bishop
but if he takes the bishop with check
thinking ah then i'm gonna take the
night nope because this very same night
is it's double parked it's gonna take
the take take the bishop and at the end
of the day we're gonna be up a pawn
we're up a pawn but we still need to
complete our development and we're not
just up any pun we're up a center pawn
it worked
it worked like a charm now he's doing
exactly what i did in the previous game
which is he's trying to open up the file
it's a pretty nasty idea
can we stop him from going f5
not physically but can we take the sting
out of that move can we
try to prevent it how who can tell me
and this is a very instructive moment
so we go g6 and after the game i will
explain
why we don't literally stop him why not
f5
there's a reason for that be patient
i'll explain that after the game
i've put i've noted it down
now why does g6 stop f5 because it adds
another defender remember pawns capture
diagonally it adds another defender to
f5 so if he goes f i will just take it
what is the other thing that this move
accomplishes
and uh first what we're going to do here
is let's lock
up the position a little bit so that we
can focus on completing our development
the other thing that it does
is that it it creates a little hole for
the bishop this is called fianchettoing
the bishop it's an italian term
which means to put the bishop on the
longest diagonal on the chessboard
either this one or this one
generally fianchettos happen on g2 b2
b7 or g7 and now we are going to
complete our development by castling
now we need to come up with a plan we
need to come up with a plan
and um we need to come up with a well
first of all
let's take a look at this night we can
trade
possible but this night let me tell you
has
perhaps the sexiest outpost of all time
where can this knight travel to
who can spot a very nice square on the
board in the center of the board
where this knight could land let's go
absolutely this is called an outpost an
outpost is a square
in your opponent's territory where a
piece cannot be bothered by
any pawns if you look at the pawns
they've advanced past this square
so they can never never chase away the
knight this is called an eternal knight
in russian now is this knight on e5
is that knight eternal
is that night eternal is this on an
outpost
can we show him that this night is no
get out of here
it ain't eternal
nope out and guess what
once he moves his knight out
if he goes back to e5 we're gonna take
it with our bishop
now why would we give up our bishop
because look at our bishop very
carefully
the bishop isn't really doing anything
anyway it's just biting on granite as i
like to say every single stream 50 times
so we might as well give it up for his
knight and rid ourselves entirely of
that
of that uh nuisance now look at this
knight versus this bishop this is a
classic case
of good knight vs bad bishop our knight
is on an outpost
his bishop is incredibly cramped
but we need a plan we can't win this
game without a plan
what could our plan look like how could
we transform
this positional advantage into something
specific what can we so there's two main
plants here we could play on the queen
side
or we could bring pieces into the king
side and try to attack his king
because i don't have much time let's do
the second thing and also because
i'm going to but we can also combine
let's combine the plans let's now go b5
to just
lend some reinforcements to b5 remember
you can combine plans and chess you can
do two things at the same time
particularly if you have very active
pieces
uh you can multitask that's okay play on
both sides so we're gonna
try to prepare the b4 pawn breakthrough
but at the same time we're gonna keep an
eye on
possibilities for attacking his king
okay and i'm gonna play a little bit
faster here now if he he knows what he's
doing he's going to play a3
to prevent me from from potentially
preparing b4 and then
i'm gonna have to redirect my attention
to to this side of the board
okay so let's first test him a little
bit let's prepare b4 hopefully
well no he doesn't go a3 so we might as
well
strike with b4 okay
why am i doing this what am i
accomplishing what i'm accomplishing
ultimately is i'm trying to open up the
b
file why is it important to open up the
file
because if we open up the file this rook
on b2 you see that
you see that it can infiltrate to b2 the
second rank
is prime real estate this is you know
central park new york real estate for
the rook and he's doing our bidding for
us he's allowing me to open up the file
for the other rook
so he there's gonna be hell today we're
gonna trade queens here
and you guys might wait a second why are
we trading queens well because we've got
more than enough pieces to checkmate him
with even without the queen's watch
okay what do we do now somebody remind
me
i've got a thing for the sub true three
false three thank you for the two months
let's go let's go let's go let's
go rook b2 infiltration
now we're going to put the other rook on
f1 it's going to be not checkmate
immediately we shouldn't rush
but he's either going to get trackmated
or he's going to lose a bunch of his
pieces so we're going to give him a
check
forcing his rope to drop out we can't
take the classic sort of
russian very old-school big zarook
look at the domination of the knight
over the bishop neither of these pieces
have moved a muscle since move 17.
so that's been the narrative of the game
that's been like the unspoken
sort of backdrop in which everything is
proceeded
without a bishop and this bishop is
essentially a big pun
he just can't play he he doesn't have
the sufficient
horse horsepower literally and
figuratively to sort of
prevent me from just ravaging his
position i'm going to push the pawn out
to a3
this pawn isn't going anywhere he gives
me a meaningless check this king could
evacuate to h6 nice little square
and here we need another plan i'm going
to play this slowly i'm going to advance
my pawns on the king side
no need to rush here because white is
completely paralyzed 150
paralyzed and this is a mistake i see a
lot of players making is just a rush
you never you don't need to rush in a
position like this you can make all the
necessary improvements
push that pass pawn down the board and
then we're going to combine that with
the other pass pawn
g3 knight defends the pawn so he cannot
take it with his bishop
okay this is a nice positional game
actually total domination the king is
perfectly safe because there's no
if he gives me a check i can go to h6 he
probably is going to give me a check
that would be my prediction although
okay rook a6 close
so g2 check okay so now what do we do
who can tell me the move and now it's
time to finally do something specific
and and win some pieces oh
nitro5 is a sexy move
oh i love that i didn't even see that
now my idea was to go rook to a1
and win as bishop that would have been
possible that would have been sort of
the
brute force method but this man uh
is a savage this knight is going to f3
what's the idea
well let's actually just ignore him
the idea is to get the knights f3
dislodge the king and then promote our
pawn and make a queen we're not even
bothering to win
any of his pieces okay king takes age
six
yeah and uh he's going to give up the
rook for the night but that doesn't help
his cause
because the game is over okay
look at this domination rook's gonna
move out and we're gonna finally we can
actually even take the bishop
we need to be careful now in such
positions remember
do not pre-move because you might
stalemate your opponent be very careful
when you've got a bunch of extra pieces
about stalemating
your opponent that's why i don't
recommend pre-moving too much unless
you're absolutely sure
that you haven't pre-moved something
which could lead to stalemate
and the game is over 48 moves and a nice
game
okay so let's unpack this he went c3 we
went knight f6 now bishop d3 is already
in inaccuracy and bishop d7
remember this idea it should be seared
in your memory by now
and i've shown you guys those of you who
are joining for the first time what i
like to do sometimes during the speed
run is to show
examples from real games that i played
in over the board tournaments
to show how i applied various ideas that
i'm
applying in the speed run and to show
how how this kind of learning proceeds
so the game that i always like to show
when we have a tactic like this
is the following game from 2010 which
reached the following position i had the
black pieces against an international
master
my rating back then was 2356 so i was a
master but not yet a grandmaster
this position that you guys now see
july 11th i played uh icelandic
international master he was rated
exactly the same
as i was rated and in this position very
complicated position
he plays the move uh bishop to g5
trying to exert pressure on my knife who
can spot my response and some of you
will remember this game i don't mean to
keep repeating it but
just want for the benefit of you know
the new people to show this one more
time
knight takes d5 is correct same exact
idea
if um bishop takes c7 then well it is a
lecture that's basically my idea
knight takes c7 that same knight gives
it a same knight that takes the pawn
takes the bishop
if he takes the knight then i take his
bishop and
the queen defense the bishop on g5 which
i applied in this game it's literally
the same thing on the other side of the
board
um thank you guys i'm i am very spoiled
and thank you crazy zamarigali for the
tier one
knight takes c5 right same exact thing
it's just a slightly different
version of it bishop is protected knight
protects the bishop
literal trans position of the pattern
g6 stopping f5 fianchettoing the bishop
we lock up the position first
we complete our development and we get
the knight to e4
now the typical mistake that i see
players make in the 18 1900 rating range
and and below is this tendency to
automatically trade
when you're up material so you're taught
when you're a beginner that when you're
up material pawn piece
you want to simplify you want to trade
and normally that's true but i've
insisted from the very start of the
speed run
that you should be very discriminating
about how you go about trading
there's no need to trade the knife
because our knight is much better than
his night
and that's why we get the knight to e4
kick his knight away
and now we get a brilliant good night
against bad bishop situation
and this is like a textbook position
i've been on the receiving end
of many such positions with a
good knight basically dominating a bad
bishop
can you give us an example i hear you
say i absolutely can if you guys just
give me one more second
and again i can't emphasize enough just
how much it's important to
to to approach your game seriously and
to to try to learn from them because
then
you're able to directly apply them look
at the following position
almost exactly the same thing watch this
this is actually kind of cool it's
almost the same squares
just a slightly different position well
look at this
this is not from the speedrun game i was
black
against the grandmaster 2009. look
knight on d5 totally dominating
completely dominating the bishop on d8
in the center of the board supported by
the pieces the bishop has no prospects
and eventually it was precisely the
night that one white the game
i eventually got my bishop out but i got
checkmated
this was from a uh a night off so coming
back to the speed run
we see a different position you know you
don't want to
over generalize but it's very very
similar the bishop is just terrible the
night is amazing
and the night is on an outpost it's
completely unassailable
okay so essentially what we did now is
we combined two plans we attacked on the
queen
side and we attacked on the king side
but he basically helped us he opened up
the file
which allowed this rook now to
infiltrate
at the correct moment to f1
rook takes g1 and we played it old
school we just traded the rope and took
the pawn that was not the only way to
win
could somebody find another possibility
in this position how else could i have
transformed my position
uh to to my favorite i'm gonna show you
guys another example from a very famous
game thank you friend 42 tier 1
now we could have played knight to f2
moistevi thank you so much i appreciate
it
exactly now this is a fork he has to
take the knight
and then we play rook f1 takes f2 this
is called piggies on the seventh
these rooks are going to massacre all of
whites pawns checkmate is threatened
white has to create some air for his
king but basically black takes
all of white's pieces and this is easily
winning now here's the thing i promise
last detour um there was a very famous
game
and the point that i want to make is
this when you have a good piece
against a bad piece such as a good night
against the bad bishop right
what you want to be very careful about
is making categorical statements like i
will never give up
um well you you never do want to give up
in general
but i will never give up my good piece
for my opponent's bad piece because
in chess you have to understand the
concept of transforming your advantage
going from one type of advantage to
another and what that sometimes requires
is giving up a piece that looks really
nice
for one of your opponent's pieces that
looks kind of bad and there was a very
very famous example of this
by none other than the man that's uh in
the photo frame behind me bobby fisher
who was playing a match for the world
championship
um against well not yet but a
candidate's match against tigran
petrossian
and he did something very very similar
here you guys go
here we go bobby fisher white 1971 one
of the most famous games actually of all
time
now this position occurred on the board
between fisher petrossian now i want you
guys to compare
look at this beautiful piece outpost
supported by a pawn
in the middle of things thank you g dark
side look at this
pathetic little bishop yarny said not
doing anything
look at this pathetic bishop guess what
bobby fischer does in this position
guess what he does he does something
that shocked the players who were
watching the game
they thought is he hallucinating
what did he do he took it
damn girl what are you doing bobby he
takes the bishop
what is he doing giving up this
beautiful knight he transforms the
advantage
because guess what he gets the c file
and look very carefully at this pawn on
a6
this is the pawn that he's going after
what he's
trying to do by taking the bishop he is
removing the primary defender of the
spawn petrossian would have put his
bishop on b5 or back to c8
and he would have kept this pawn
protected so what fisher decides is i'm
going to go after that pawn
by trying to get my rook to c6 but
trojan stops him but much like in our
game
fisher gets one rook to the seventh rank
and i'm gonna fast forward
fast forward and he gets the other rook
to the seventh round so quite literally
it's a very similar narrative here
and he checkmates black petrosian
resigned here because uh he cannot stop
the rook
maneuvering itself to h8 i don't want to
go through the
details of this but that's just to show
you guys that this kind of stuff happens
all the time
okay um so that was
that was that game so back to the speed
on transformation transformation of the
advantage now we decided to go old
school
taking the rook taking the pawn and just
promoting
our pawns now knight g5 was a really
nice move uh preparing knight f3 we
could have also gone to rook a1 that was
my intention
and taking the bishop and leaving us up
a night okay
um you were going to explain f5 instead
of gc thank you for reminding me
it is in my notebook i appreciate it why
did i not
just brute force stop f5 with the five
could somebody explain this to me
narrative i like it
that is not the same tigran petrossian
unfortunately he passed away in the 80s
the world champion
today's tigran petrossian is a grand
master same name different person
we weaken the e6 pawn now actually
ladies and gentlemen it's not queen h5
check this is innocuous
because black can go g6 to block the
check
okay so that's that is part of it but
that's not strictly speaking the reason
the reason is the pawn on e6 look at how
weak it is
and the definition of a weak pawn is
upon it cannot be protected by any other
pawns right that's the dictionary
definition
uh but not all weak pawns are bad it's
just that this one is
very easy to attack because it's also an
artery to the king
got to be very careful about that not a
disaster we can defend it
but why allow something like this why
give white a target okay
hopefully that makes sense so that's why
i played g6 now this pawn is nicely
protected rookie one is innocuous
we can just keep developing so
what's the lesson here be very careful
about creating what's called a backward
pawn a pawn that's behind
its neighbors particularly one that's
next to your king every time you push a
pawn out like this
especially the f pawn just try to very
quickly
check to see whether you create any
weaknesses and whether these weaknesses
are easy to attack
okay what would you take with if he had
pushed f5 well if he had pushed f5
i would have definitely taken the g pawn
to keep that e file closed i should
definitely would not have taken to the e
pawn and allowed something like this to
happen
[Music]
you